ready to not have a baby in my belly
anymore
me too me too mommy's tired
well dreams do come true alec and
ellaria baldwin welcomed baby number
five
monday night you have kids and
if you're like us sometimes you feel
like you can't stop having kids
every time we have them
elaria shared a picture of her and alec
holding their new baby boy
at the hospital writing he is perfect
and we couldn't be happier
stay tuned for a name mommy want another
one after this one
mommy doesn't even want to think about
another one right now
but we'll see we'll see if she bullies
me into it
the couple are already parents to their
four children
six-year-old carmen five-year-old
raphael three-year-old leonardo and
two-year-old romeo
alec is also dad to 24 year old daughter
ireland whom he shares with his ex-wife
kim basinger
ellaria announced she was pregnant in
april after
suffering a miscarriage four months
prior something she opened up to e.t
about last year
personally i believe when you go through
something difficult the sooner that you
make it real the sooner you can do with
do something with it and it was
something that you don't want to be real
i kept on waking up and thinking it was
a bad dream and it wasn't
but the more that you talk about it the
more you make it real and when you
it's real then you can work on it and
it's also you know a silver lining even
though this is something that i
did not want to go through and would
never ever want to go through again
has been that how many people come
forward and said that they have
more courage to share these kinds of
things it's much more common than you
think
i've got a very good husband who's been
there with me the whole time bringing me
into the surgery and
sort of being there when i wake up even
though her pregnancy didn't go as
planned
things turned around for the couple
she happily shared their rival a baby
number five
writing i'll let the baby do the talking
because i don't have the words to
express how this sound makes us feel
just got the great news that all is well
and all is healthy with this
little munchkin